OF CORONAVIRUS.
ALL THAT AHEAD.
♪.
MARIA: NOW THE LATEST ON
CORONAVIRUS TODAY, THERE HAS
BEEN OVER 26000 CASES IN THE
U.S.
MORE THAN 340 PEOPLE ARE NOW
DEAD.
MORE THAN 311,000 CASES AND
13000 DEATHS WORLDWIDE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS RAISED
A GLOBAL TRAVEL ADVISORY TO A
LEVEL FOUR, THAT IS THE AGENCY’S
TOP WARNING LEVEL, IT IS
RECOMMENDED THAT U.S. CITIZENS
REMAIN IN PLACE OR RETURN HOME.
THIS WEEKEND AT LEAST EIGHT
STATES WITH GUIDELINES TO STAY
HOME.
JOINING ME AS ACTING SECRETARY
OF HOMELAND SECURITY CHAD WOLF.
THEY COULD SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
CHAD: IT IS GOOD TO BE WITH YOU
THIS MORNING.
MARIA: LET’S GET TO THE VERY
LATEST, THE U.S. CLOSING ITS
BORDER WITH MEXICO, CLOSING THE
CANADIAN BORDER EFFECTIVE THIS
WEEKEND.
IS THE PRESIDENT CONSIDERING A
FULL SHUTDOWN OF THE COUNTRY?
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME?
CHAD: NOT AT THIS TIME, THE
PRESIDENT AND THE VICE PRESIDENT
IN THE TASK FORCE HAS BEEN VERY
AGGRESSIVE AND VERY FORWARD
LEANING IN THE NUMBER OF
GUIDANCE AND INFORMATION TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, WE HAVE 15 DAYS
TO SLOW THE SPREAD, THERE’S A
NUMBER OF MAJORS ASKING AMERICAN
PUBLIC TO TAKE, THERE HAS BEEN A
NUMBER OF GOVERNORS, NEW YORK
AND CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE TAKEN
THE EXTRA STEP AND IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL STRICT MEASURES, WE
AGREE WITH THOSE MAJORS, THERE
WILL BE CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION THAT NEED TO TAKE
MORE AGGRESSIVE MEASURES THAN
PERHAPS OTHER COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM IN THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNORS TO DO
THAT AND WE CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO TAKE THOSE
AGGRESSIVE MEASURES.
MARIA: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
AGGRESSIVE MEASURES, I AM IN NEW
YORK AND THERE IS A STATEWIDE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER OR GUIDELINE
BEGINNING SUNDAY AT 8:00 P.M.,
CALIFORNIA IS ON LOCKDOWN, IT
FEELS LIKE IT IS A SHUTDOWN.
YOU WILL NOT DO THAT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BUT IT’S EFFECTIVE
ENOUGH TO DO IN LARGE STATES?
CHAD: AGAIN, I THINK WERE
FOCUSING ON THOSE STATES AND
THOSE LOCALITIES THAT HAVE
WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION, NEW YORK,
CALIFORNIA, WASHINGTON AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THAT WERE
SEEING CASES SPIKE, THOSE
GOVERNORS ARE LOOKING AT THOSE
NUMBERS CLOSELY AND IN TOUCH
WITH THE CDC AND HHS AND THE
TASK FORCE, WERE SHARING THAT
INFORMATION AND IN THOSE
LOCALITIES IN LOCATIONS LIKE NEW
YORK CITY, THEY HAVING TO TAKE
AGGRESSIVE MEASURES TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
THERE’S OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY PERHAPS IN THE MIDWEST
AND SOUTH THAT ARE NOT SEEING
THE SAME NUMBERS.
THEY DON’T NEED TO TAKE THOSE
AGGRESSIVE MEASURES AT THIS
TIME.
WE EVALUATE THIS ON A DAY BY DAY
WEEK BY WEEK BASIS.
MARIA: IT’S LIKE WHEN YOU AND I
WERE TALKING ON THE PHONE THIS
WEEKEND AND YOU SAY IF WE SHUT
DOWN NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA,
MAYBE YOU DON’T HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN NEBRASKA, MAYBE THAT’S A
CHIP YOU USE LATER ON, IS THAT
THE THINKING?
CHAD: THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT, WE
WANT TO TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE
SEEING LARGE NUMBERS AND
OUTBREAKS SO WE DO NOT HAVE TO
TAKE THOSE MEASURES ELSEWHERE IF
WE DO NOT NEED TO.
THAT IS THE CONCEPT BEHIND IT, I
WOULD SAY THERE ARE MAJORS THAT
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN
TAKE REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU ARE
AT, THE 15 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
CAME ON THE TASK FORCE CAME OUT
WITH, A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ANY AMERICAN CAN
TAKE ANYWHERE THEY LIVE, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN HIGH TRANSMISSION
AREAS LIKE NEW YORK CITY, LIKE
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA, THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING THEM TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL MEASURES SO WE CAN
CONTROL THE SPREAD AND MITIGATE
THAT.
MARIA: TELL ME ABOUT THE CDC
CHANGES, WHAT WE HEARD THIS
WEEKEND FROM THE CENTER OF
DISEASE CONTROL AND WHY THAT IS
IMPORTANT, I WANT OUR AUDIENCE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE CDC NEW
REGULATION THIS WEEKEND.
CHAD: ON FRIDAY THE CDC GAVE AN
ORDER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY THAT SAID
SUSPEND THE ENTRY OF ANY
INDIVIDUAL COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT PROPER
DOCUMENTATION.
THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT REASONS, ONE
WITHOUT THE DOCUMENTATION WE SEE
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT PROPER IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS, WITHOUT TRAVEL
DOCUMENTS, WITHOUT MEDICAL
HISTORY, IT’S VERY HARD TO MAKE
A PUBLIC HEALTH DETERMINATION ON
THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
THERE ALSO CONCERNED, THE CDC
ABOUT TAKING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
INTO CUSTODY AND PUTTING THEM
INTO BORDER PATROL FACILITIES
AND ICE FACILITIES WHAT PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS AND ISSUES THAT
READ THIS PREVIEW RAISES A
NUMBER OF THOSE ISSUES, SERIOUS
DANGER TO NOT ONLY ALIENS BUT
CERTAINLY THE DHS WORKFORCE IN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AT LARGE.
THE CDC WAS SAID WE NEED TO
SUSPEND THAT SO THAT’S WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST 24 HOURS AND I WOULD
SAY IT IS WORKING, WE SEE ALMOST
A 50% DROP IN ILLEGAL
APPREHENSIONS, THOSE ILLEGAL
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS OUR
BORDERS.
MARIA: THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT IS NOT JUST AIR BORDERS BUT
IT’S ALSO LAND BORDERS.
CHAD: THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT, WE
PUT IN MAJORS FROM 30 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES, TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS,
THE PRESIDENT DID, VERY
AGGRESSIVE AND VERY FORWARD
LEANING VERY EARLY ON IN THIS
PROCESS EARLY IN FEBRUARY, WE
ARE TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS FROM 30
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO
AIRPORTS.
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT LAND
PORTS OF ENTRY AND MERE PORTS OF
ENTRY.
WE ARE DOING OPERATE ALSO
ANNOUNCED ON FRIDAY IS LIMITING
ESSENTIAL TRAVEL ACROSS OUR LAND
PORTS OF ENTRY BOTH WITH CANADA
AND MEXICO.
NOW WHAT WERE ASKING,
NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL AND
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR TOURISM, RECREATIONAL
SERVICES, IF YOU WANT TO GO TO
YOUR LOCAL FAVORITE RESTAURANT,
WE ARE ASKING YOU NOT TO DO
THAT, WE’RE TRYING NOT TO CLOSE
THE BORDER AND TRYING TO KEEP
THE BORDER OPEN, WERE TRYING TO
KEEP MAJORS IN PLACE SO WE CAN
KEEP THE LEGITIMATE TRADE AND
TRAVEL AND CONTINUE TO FLOW
ACROSS CANADA AND MEXICAN
BORDERS.
WHAT WE SEE EVERY DAY, HAS
$1.7 BILLION IN TRADE AND
COMMERCE THAT FLOW ACROSS THE
U.S. CANADIAN BORDER, THAT’S
EVERYDAY ABOUT 1.5 BILLION IN
MEXICO EVERY SINGLE DAY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE THE
TRADE AND KEEP THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND KEEP THE ECONOMY RUNNING
INTAKE MAJORS NOW TO LIMIT THAT
ESSENTIAL TRAVEL AND TO LIMIT
THE INTRODUCTION AND SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS.
MARIA: WHICH LEADS ME TO THE
ISSUE OF RETHINKING THE
CORONAVIRUS STRATEGY, NO DOUBT
YOU SAW THE OP-ED IN THE JOURNAL
LAST WEEK WHICH WAS QUESTIONING
THE STRATEGY BECAUSE IT’S
PUTTING OUR ECONOMY TO A
STANDSTILL.
I WILL GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
I HAVE TO ASK ABOUT DOMESTIC
TRAVEL, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WONDERING, THEY SEE REPORTS THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS CONSIDERING
SHUTTING DOWN ALL DOMESTIC
TRAVEL FOR 30 DAYS.
CHAD: WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT IT,
THERE IS NO IMMEDIATE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS ON DOMESTIC TRAVEL,
WE CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HIGH TRANSMISSION
AREAS LIKE NEW YORK, LIKE PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT
AND IF WE SEE WE NEED TO PUT
TARGETED TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS IN
PLACE WE WILL DO THAT.
I WILL SAY THERE’S NO IMMEDIATE
PLANS AS OF RIGHT NOW FOR ANY
WIDESPREAD TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS.
MARIA: IF WE LOOK AT THE
TIMELINE IN TERMS OF THE
TIMELINE OF BORDER CLOSING, THIS
HAS BEEN PRETTY CONSISTENT IN
TERMS OF CLOSING ACTIVITY, WHAT
IS THE THREAT, HOW WORRIED ARE
YOU THAT WE WILL SEE A SHUTDOWN
OF THE U.S. ECONOMY, MOST PEOPLE
ARE EXPECTING A RECESSION, SOME
PEOPLE TALKING WORSE THAN THAT,
WHAT IS THE THINKING AROUND ALL
THE SHUTDOWNS AND THE IMPACT OF
A 20 TRILLION-DOLLAR ECONOMY?
>> AGAIN, THE DISCUSSIONS WE
HAVE ON THE TASK FORCE CERTAINLY
CONSIDER THE ECONOMY AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING ON THAT BUT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THE VIRUS.
THAT IS FIRST AND THAT’S WHAT WE
LOOK AT IN THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS GO TO JUST THAT AND
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD, LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF CASES THAT THEY HAVE
TO SEE IF ADDITIONAL TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS NEED TO BE PUT IN
PLACE, ONE IS A CONTAINMENT OR
MITIGATION STRATEGY, MAKING SURE
WE DO NOT CONTINUE TO IMPORT
THEY VIRUS INTO THE U.S. AND WE
TRY TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC BUT THEN OF COURSE
THERE’S ALREADY TRANSMISSION
HERE IN THE U.S., WHAT ARE THE
MAJORS WERE PUTTING IN PLACE
DOMESTICALLY IN A VARIETY OF
MEASURES AND TASK FORCE
ANNOUNCES MAJORS EVERY SINGLE
DAY TO DO THAT AND SO IT’S A
TWO-PRONGED STRATEGY IN A
TWO-PRONGED APPROACH, THE MAJOR
WERE TAKEN AT THE BORDER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY PERSPECTIVE TO MAKE
SURE WERE LETTING THAT TRADE AND
COMMERCE FLOW, WE HAVE TO KEEP
THE ECONOMY MOVING, WE REALIZE
THAT, THE EASIEST THING IS TO
SHUT DOWN THE BORDERS
COMPLETELY, LET NO ONE IN, WE
REALIZE WE CANNOT DO THAT, THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY WILL NOT
SURVIVE THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT
THOUGHTFUL RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE
TO KEEP THE CARGO AND KEEP THE
TRADE MOVING.
MARIA: REALLY QUICK ONLY A
COUPLE OF SECONDS, YOU WANTED TO
MENTION THIS INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN WHICH CONTINUES, WE
KNOW THIS CAMPAIGN COMING OUT OF
CHINA BUT WHEN PEOPLE SEE
REPORTS, IT MAY VERY WELL BE
CYBER FRAUD RIGHT?
CHAD: ABSOLUTELY, WE’VE SEEN THE
NUMBER OF REPORTS AND I
PERSONALLY HAVE GOTTEN CONTACTED
A NUMBER OF TIMES ABOUT TEXT
MESSAGES AND SCREENSHOTS GOING
AROUND SAYING I KNOW SOMEONE AT
DHS AND THEY SAY WE WILL HAVE A
NATIONAL LOCKDOWN OR NATIONAL
QUARANTINE, I WOULD SAY THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY FALSE, THAT IS NOT
TRUE AND PART OF A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN, WHAT WE
KNOW WHETHER RUSSIA OR OTHER
CYBER ACTORS, THEY LIKE TO SO
DISCORD ON ANY CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE, IT DOES NOT JUST HAVE TO
BE ELECTION, IT CAN BE ANY ISSUE
AND WERE SEEN IN OUR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
I WOULD SAY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, DON’T BELIEVE IT, DON’T
PASS IT ALONG AND GET YOUR
INFORMATION FROM TRUSTED SOURCES
SUCH AS YOUR STATE OFFICIALS AND
FEDERAL OFFICIALS.
MARIA: YOU WILL HAVE AN UPDATE
BY MIDDLE OF APRIL, AND OF APRIL
TO FIGURE OUT IF THIS IS
WORKING, YOU WILL HAVE AN UPDATE
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR NOT THE
MOVES YOU’VE TAKEN HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL?
CHAD: CERTAINLY THE DOCTORS ON
THE TASK FORCE, CDC, HHS AND THE
LIKE ARE REALLY TRACKING A DAY
BY DAY, WHAT I WILL SAY SOME OF
THE MAJORS WE ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE, THE AGGRESSIVE MEASURES
WERE PUTTING IN PLACE, WE NEED
TO PUT THOSE IN PLACE NOW TO SEE
RESULTS IN THREE - 4 - 5 WEEKS
FROM NOW, THEY MAY BE IN
COMFORTABLE THAT YOU SEE IN NEW
YORK, CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE
BUT WERE DOING THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE GOVERNORS
SO WE CAN SEE RESULTS IN THE
THREE, FOUR, FIVE WEEK.
I THINK WE WILL SEE NUMBERS IN
APRIL SOMETIME TO KNOW IF THE
MAJORS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE ARE
WORKING.
MARIA: SECRETARY, IT’S GOOD TO
SEE YOU THIS MORNING THANK YOU
FOR UPDATING US.
ACTING HOMELAND SECRETARY CHAD
WOLF JOINING US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL KEEP IN TOUCH, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WORKING WITH
BUSINESSES TO RAMP UP MEDICAL
SUPPLY, A SURGE OF CORONAVIRUS
TAKES US IN THE UNITED STATES,
THREATENING SHORTAGES, WHITE
HOUSE PETER NAVARRO WILL JOIN ME
NEXT WITH AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
STAY WITH US.
Being able to retire.
On our terms.